[Musique]
des marionnettes géantes une fanfare la
parade d'ouverture du festival août est
lancée ce jeudi 29 août et durant trois
jours ce nouveau festival dédié à la
valorisation de l'environnement de la
vallée de chevreuse des espaces naturels
et des artistes étaient mis en avant au
travers d'animations originales
au programme une visite de la ferme de
coubertin avec dégustation de fromages
pour les petits gourmands un moment pour
venir contempler les expositions
d'oeuvres d'art
de profiter des nombreux spectacles
[Musique]
de venir participer à des ateliers
créatifs pour petits et grands et une
projection de films en plein air avec
pas moins de 400 spectateurs
[Musique]
pour ce dernier week-end avant la
rentrée scolaire
la ville a misé sur une première édition
du festival mêlant patrimoine
environnement et spectacles un pari
réussi pour la mairie de la ville qui
n'hésitera pas à renouveler l'expérience
[Musique]